hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in a discussion
that begins in chapter 8 of his on
friendship Cicero grapples with really
an age-old question or a problem that
arises for many people even in the
present as a matter of fact it is so
common so ubiquitous that not only can
you find it in advice columns and you
know reddit relationships and pick
whatever else you like we also make
movies about it and television shows
about it it's kind of a common plot what
do you do when somebody who you're
friends with somebody who you have this
relationship affection and mutual
goodwill and some sort of commonality
probably a common history with the
person somebody to whom you you feel an
obligation of loyalty what do you do
when they ask you to do something that
you know is wrong and they probably also
know is wrong should you do it because
you're friends with them and you love
them or should you refuse it knowing
that it's likely going to not only hurt
their feelings but damage the very
relationship that you have this is a
very common issue and it arise
is very frequently within friendships
and so Cicero considers it in terms of
some pretty famous people but we can
easily relate it to our own cases and he
says that this is one of the things that
disagreements often arise within
friendships because of he says that
there there's a demand upon friends to
do something wrong and so what are some
of the examples that he gives to become
agents of Vice right to join somebody
else in doing something something wrong
something morally depraved something as
we would say vicious and he's not
talking about vice like smoking or
drinking or you know playing cards or
whatever else is being proud of he's
talking about joining in in say being
cowards or being too rash or being
intemperate you know should you join
people in drinking parties where it goes
on until you throw up and then you drink
some more no that that's that's you know
a bad way of behaving well what if
that's what your friends expect from you
you know this is a very common problem
especially for young people so becoming
agents of ice or abetters in violence
going after other people let's join in
and bullying this person over here and
if you don't do it you're not my friend
so he says when the demand is refused
however honorable the refusal it's
charged by those to whom the complacence
was denied that the laws of friendship
have been disregarded so what happens
some people give in and that's not good
because if you're giving in to doing
something you know is wrong or
dishonorable injurious to other people
what does that person think about you
some refuse in any case the friendship
is altered if you give in they know that
they'll you'll go along with what it is
that they expect now you know in the
case of lovers who are requiring proofs
of their love from from each other
maybe they they don't you know view you
in a lower light at least not a right
a but over time they might and if there
isn't that sort of relationship they
they might say oh well that person does
go along with it I guess they're not the
good person I thought they were so he
says that those who dare demand anything
and everything of a friend by that very
demand profess a willingness to do
anything whatever for the sake of a
friend now that's that's not always true
though is it sometimes people expect
things of us and they don't give that
loyalty in return they call themselves
are our friends but they're not really
our friends and so he says by these
careless recriminations not only our
social intimacy's often destroyed but
also everlasting hatreds are produced so
when you have these fateful demands
cross this line this line that is
consisting in something wrong something
shameful something harmful something
unjust just actually demanding that of
another person already changes the
nature of the friendship so this raises
a fundamental question how far should
and here's the through use of the word
love a more go in friendship iMac it's
the up how far should our love or our
loyalty to the other person drive us
what should we be willing to do and what
should we draw the line on and say no
we're not going to allow that so he
talks about a number of famous cases I'm
gonna skip over those and only look at
one which is this example of Gaius Blow
--ss a protege says of you know one
other the interlocutors family came to
me to plead for leniency because I was
present as an advisor and offered as a
reason for my pardoning him because he'd
done something wrong the fact that his
esteem for Tiberius graças who was a
very charismatic leader was so great he
thought it was his duty to do anything
that siberius requested him to do and so
you know this is a common situation
isn't it I love this person so much I
admire them so much they're such they've
been so good to me i whatever they want
me to do I have to do I am you know if
not their slave or their servant I am
their loyal retainer their friend their
companion I'll do anything that has to
be done really hide hide bodies that
were you know assassinated cover up you
know financial improprieties what about
and here's the example he gives what
about burning down the Capitol now that
may not like that big of a deal to us
but for the Romans that was sort of like
saying would you do the worst thing that
we can think of I mean I suppose the
only other thing that would been even
worse than that maybe raping the Vestal
Virgins or something along those lines
profaning all the temples this was a big
deal and so the guy says well you know
Tiberius would never ask me to do that
because he's a good guy but I guess if
he did I'd do it and so he doesn't get
leniency because that is not the right
way to be that's the wrong answer to
give and it's the wrong answer to give
because it's the wrong position to take
he says what an impious remark that was
and he said he did all that he said he
would or rather even more he directed
the infatuation of Tiberius Gracchus and
it goes on and this is this is a real
problem when people are willing to
follow a friend in this way and do
anything that they they require well
they'll they'll transgress any laws or
norms or or you know requirements so he
goes on and he says that good people
people who have the capacity to be good
friends by the way they think that it's
wrong to make or to grant bad request
requests that require you if you're
going to comply with them to do
something wrong
he says that we shouldn't grant our
friends whatever they wish or get from
them whatever we wish unless were these
are the right things to do
we shouldn't be engaging in that sort of
behavior so he talks now about
establishing a law that it's not the
originating this idea right because he's
already brought up the fact that when
friends get into these sorts of
situations they often think the laws of
friendship have been broken so Cicero
here is proposing a revision of the law
of friendship a rectification of the law
and if first he frames it in a negative
way he says that let this law be
established in friendship neither ask
dishonorable things nor do them if asked
and dishonorable things race troupis
right things that are wrong things that
are disgusting things that are unjust
things that we we know we shouldn't do
so we shouldn't ask our friends to do
things of this this sort it's violating
the law of friendship to do that if the
friend does that we should refuse
we should not comply with their wishes
even though we love them even though
we're friends with them because it's the
wrong thing we should not grant those
requests and then he goes a little bit
further and he notes something you could
say on a certain metal level
he says dishonorable it certainly is and
not to be allowed for anyone to plead in
defense of sins in general and
especially of those against the state
that he committed them for the sake of a
friend don't justify these sorts of
requests don't justify these sorts of
actions by saying that friendship made
me do it
or complying with my love with somebody
or admiration for somebody drove me to
do the wrong thing they asked me to do
like burning down the Capitol or
falsifying records or joining it on
bullying somebody or whatever it happens
to me or even requests that would be
demeaning for yourself
that you shouldn't give in to things
that are humiliating that perhaps a
lover demands or a friend demands as
tokens of your your being part of the
club being part of the gang being part
of the the group now he also has a more
positive formulation of this law of
friendship as well and so this is a
little bit you know more extensive than
the other he says let this be ordained
as the first law of friendship ask of
friends only what is honorable only what
do for friends only what is honorable
and without even waiting to be asked and
honorable here is the opposite of turpis
it's honesta the things that we with the
word we get honesty from right but it
has a connotation here not just of
truthfulness but of being right being
the good thing to do overall and he goes
on and adds a few other things he says
let zeal be ever present but hesitation
anson dare to give true advice with all
frankness in friendship let the
influence of friends who are wise
counselors be paramount let that
influence be employed in advising not
only with frankness but if the occasion
demands even with sternness and let the
advice be given when let the advice be
followed when given this is actually you
know quite positive now frankness what
does frankness mean another word for it
is freedom of speech not freedom of
speech in the sense that nobody should
you know restrict you from doing it at
any expression that you want to do
rather freedom of speech or frankness of
speech in this case means being able to
tell people the hard truths that they
need to hear a later on in the work
sister will tell us how to to carry out
criticism of friends and will say that
this is something important for
maintaining friendship so we shouldn't
do things that are bad we shouldn't go
along with friends going along to get
along
all right
proverb goes and instead we should do
the things that are that are right and
try to encourage our friends by doing
these things and only ask of them what
is is right for them and for other
people so the long and short of this is
once we get to the point where friends
are demanding wrongful things of friends
we got a serious problem with the
friendship and it's probably a sign that
things have already started to go wrong
in the character of the people and in
the nature of their relationship it's a
difficult topic but one that was just as
important back then as it remains today
you